noticed something that was wrong with
the way he was moving around and praying
and capture this man by pinning him to
the ground
i've done the seventh day free trial of
the qurani app and it exceeded all my
expectations prophecy you can build a
habit with the quran by seven day free
trial bonuses not credit card details
required at all and you decide for
yourself is it overrated or is it
underrated assalamu alaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh brothers and
sisters and dear friends hope you guys
are well inshallah so i thought i'll
change up the setup a bit inshallah
inspired
he's collecting some money for patreon
to help him have an editor please go
check that out as well inshallah
bless him he inspires us to you know
improve uh our setup but today's video
is actually very serious and i saw this
video it actually came across me and i
was like ah you know i i wasn't feeling
to do any videos i'll be honest with you
but when i saw it i was like it's so
profound let's watch this video this is
a video of a magician in the kaaba
in mecca the holy land
where taheed
is the land of tahit
and he attempts magic this is the video
let's watch it for ourselves and we send
shivers down everyone's fine in saudi
arabia a man was found practicing black
magic inside majida haram during ramzan
and quite close to the kaaba he was with
his wife and they were wearing an iran
to disguise themselves among the normal
worshippers the authorities noticed
something that was wrong with the way he
was moving around and praying and
capture this man by pinning him to the
ground they searched him up and down and
confiscated some unknown materials from
it shockingly they found tight knots
with spells laced on it and together
with an unknown religious figure to help
them they proceeded to untie the knots
and cut it with a knife to release the
spells they did all of this whilst
reciting holy verses from the quran to
protect them the saudi arabian
authorities took him in but no one
really knows what happened to him after
that and there isn't an update all we
know is that according to saudi arabian
law witchcraft is punishable by death
so as you guys saw there the gods
realized that he was doing something a
bit ajib didn't seem ordinary you know
um the way he was praying maybe the way
he was moving and the people that he was
with now if you notice very clearly on
the video which you can see on my left
is that
he is the the the people that probably
got some scholars um who came and they
recite the quran you know
whatever it may be and they started
cutting up and one thing that you will
notice is that these things have not
they always have a lot of knots not
snots and this is how they do magic i
was doing a bit of research on youtube
um just looking around and there's even
a tutorial of someone actually a woman
it looks like hindu woman who is
actually teaching you how to do these
and this is very ajib and strange you
know that you cast the spell and you do
you do the not etcetera surely enough at
the time of the prophet peace be upon
him um the prophet sallallahu was
actually attacked by
now some of you guys might hear this and
be like what the message of god how
could he be affected by sir very
important key things that we need to
learn in this video brothers and sisters
the process of sallam yes was the
message of allah the best man to walk
this earth a mercy to mankind but the
things the trials he went through is
also for us to learn as human beings
because you need to understand he was
also a human beings there is decisions
that he made that were not wahi there
was this is that he made that sometimes
the companions would uh would introduce
an idea which might
be something that allah subhanahu
for example picked this well for example
when it came to the battle of mother let
go of the
captives etc so the human element is
there and anyone who thinks that the
process this cannot happen to the
messenger of god etc um from what i know
this is basically people of innovation
who declare no impossible no allah
teaches lesson and one lesson that i
believe by doing to double thinking
about this is that the prophet peace be
upon him the reason why his these things
happen and maybe the pro the why allah
has caused certain things to happen at
the prophet peace be upon him is so we
do not glorify him to the level where
the people of the book the christians
did with jesus peace be upon him that
they have now deified him or calling the
son of god or he's some part of a god
etc is to show us the human side because
when we speak to the christians what did
they tell us they tell us oh but
christian is i mean jesus was sinless he
was sinners they kept talking about his
sin and sins etc we believe
all the the prophets of god almighty god
almighty are
they are innocent
the point i'm trying to make here is
that it's that we do not fall into that
and even though in today's time we still
have people that look at look at the
prophet salallahu salem and even go to
his graves and ask him
directly for things that they want this
could be a lesson maybe the hikmah
behind it is that the allah is teaching
us that the messenger of allah he's the
prophet salallahu
there he's also human being
that's one thing that we can take from
this video secondly when it comes to the
issue of
magic etc you need to understand this
person to travel to mecca and do this
shows you that these creatures these
beings these jinns or shayateen whoever
they may be they ask you to do things
that are on levels on tabaka there are
levels the worst that you do the more
doors they open for you and they work
for you etc obviously the aim is for you
to commit ship
because there's hadith of the prophet
peace be upon him which says by abdullah
abdullah reported that the prophet peace
be upon him said verily spells amulets
and charms are acts of idolatry okay so
brother and sister that even spells that
for example magic
because you will be yes it will open the
doors for you to the unseen and certain
things that you might be able to see but
it will come at the cost of this belief
it is not worth it that might be the
reason why this man traveled all the way
there all the way there just to do that
in the holy land god knows what these
jinns promised them god knows allah
knows best but how do we deal with the
issue of sihar in surah verse 102 allah
directly talks about this and there are
some lessons we can take from this so
let's read it so it says they instead
follow the magic promoted by the devils
during their reign of solomon never did
solomon disbelieve rather the devil's
disbelief so allah subhanahu was
rebuking the bible and certain
individuals who claim that
sulaiman is the one who who did magic or
taught magic yeah which is alike i was
defending the honor of the
prophet of allah rather the devil
disbelieved they taught magic to the
people along along with what had been
revealed to the two angels
and maru these are the two angels that
came down okay so okay so in babylon
the two angels never taught anyone
without saying were only a test for you
so do not abandon your faith yet people
learn magic that cause the rift between
husband and wife
is one main element is useful is to
divide husband and wife although their
magic could not harm anyone except by
allah's will they learned they learned
what harmed them and what did not
benefit them although they already knew
whatever that whoever buys into the
magic would have no share in the
hereafter like for example i asked my
teacher this i said why would the angels
come and teach magic so my teacher said
to me if you think about it he said why
is that alco why are there certain
things allah subhanahu ta'ala has placed
on the earth why because it is there as
a test for you we can't come and say
okay if allah wants me to stay away from
alcohol why is there alcohol what's the
point of the test of course it's going
to be there and there's going to be
certain things that's going to tempt you
but the angels made it very clear do not
do it do not let go of your faith and
what did they do they did the opposite
so guys i don't want to long this video
video up that much
what you saw there is disturbing and
there are people that will go to these
lengths to do this however the point
we're trying to make brother and sisters
is protect yourself because just one
thing that i forgot to mention
when the prophet muhammed peace be upon
him was
attacked by allah
and surah nas and if you recite these
two soras it will protect you with
ayatul kursi and doing your afkar in
morning and evening inshallah you can
recite
[Music]
[Music]